such a good movie I love this so much uh
Gabrielle I know cavia just had an
encounter themed birthday party how
excited is she that her mom gets to be a
character in her own Disney movie she's
very excited but she's a little confused
um trying to understand like where I fit
in and where my voice is coming in uh
but she'll be at the premiere uh in a
couple days so she'll actually get to
see it all sort of come together and you
know the full form but she's very
excited you know she's heard me on the
proud family and I'm the voice of Nala
on the lion guard but this is my first
big you know animated movie and she's
pumped I mean if the Encanto
uh this has been years within Kanto now
so I'd like to think that maybe for her
next birthday she'll want to be mom
right I doubt it but maybe maybe we're
putting it out to the universe
uh Jake why are you so excited to be a
part of this movie and kind of the
message that they really explore with
parents and kids
well I I mean I always think the idea
what I love about it from the beginning
was the idea that the family is kind of
the microcosm for how we treat the world
around us you know like how we treat
each other within that microcosm is how
we eventually go out into the world and
and treat each other and so and the
environment around us so I loved that
idea and I love the idea of the
complications of generations trying to
understand each other you know
um who doesn't get that you know and and
having to work through it to to save
each other they had to face their own
stubbornness and they have to in order
to get to a place where they can all
survive and to me the those things that
you resist you know are often the things
that teach you the most and so that's
all the clades have to learn in this and
I love that I love that about it I love
that uh I was just talking to Dennis and
jabuki and I asked them if you could
live in your own Strange World something
that would be strange to others but not
so much for you what would that world
look like my house
judging from the comment section I
clearly my house is the strangest World
there is what you listen to your kids
what you treat everyone with respect and
kindness what it's I guess my house yeah
I'm gonna have to go to Gabrielle's
house too I'm gonna go with Gabrielle's
house too Dev absolutely
hands down Gabriel is there room for
Jake in your house absolutely absolutely
all the women in my house uh will find a
spot
um for Jake Grandpa's out but Jake is in
for Thanksgiving sorry Dad
um
I love that do you get used to people
having so many I mean really great
opinions about you and your family
because people love watching you guys
some are great yeah some are great uh
those are mostly my mom
um but yeah I think you know if you live
out loud and you're not afraid
um to be exactly who you are and loving
each other for exactly as we all want to
appear in the world and we are in the
world
um
people are going to have things to say
because we're afraid and we always want
to have you know make sure our way is
the right way you know what I mean and
anything outside of that feels like a
threat or dangerous or suspicious
um but I've learned you know through a
lot of failure and a lot of uh heartache
that there's a billion ways to exist on
this planet there's a billion ways to
love one another but if you always
Center
um Peace Grace love and you know peace
you can't go wrong so that's how we live
I guess if that's strange you know
welcome to Strange World it's a good
time the water's warm
I love that I got the wrap my truck yeah
that was a double piece she began with
peas and ended with peace I think that's
where we should finish this you know
it's done we're done
thanks so much you guys really
appreciate it